the new plans by the government not
unveiled yet we are expecting them
perhaps to be outlined tomorrow
um but it seems very clear what the
government's objective is in fact
Richard Cena saying over the weekend
make no mistake if you come here
illegally you will not be able to stay
your reaction to this tightening of the
laws by the UK government
it's it's utterly dismal it does nothing
to fix the absolute mess the government
has made of the UK's Asylum system which
is costing an awful lot of money and
doing a lawful lot of harm to people
it is exactly the policy in fact that
the government has been pursuing for at
least the last four years from excessive
uh uh measures by successive home
secretaries simply designed to avoid
this country's responsibilities
responsibilities that this country
expects others should take and indeed
others do take in far greater volume
than do we and in lesson until we are
going to Buck Up and simply get on with
the job of Fairly and efficiently
deciding the claims that are actually
made here I'm afraid things are going to
get significantly worse
yes an interesting point you make there
and one that should be talked about in
in the context of this is the backlog of
Asylum claims those who come to the UK
can seek Asylum once they're here but
once they're in that system we're
talking months years are we any clearer
as to why
that is taking so long
it's it's manifestly clear why it's
taking so long it's because the
government decided a few years ago
particularly at the end end of 2020
to effectively refuse to process
people's claims it took the ridiculous
decision that somehow it would persuade
other countries who already take far
more responsibility than do we
to receive our responsibilities for
people on top of their own
of course it was never going to be
practical it won't be now
and so simply ratcheting up that exact
same policy by Evermore legislation
can't resolve the backlog because
whether the number of people making new
claims goes up or down if people don't
get out of your system the backlog must
get bigger and that's exactly what's
happened over the last four years and we
are in an utter mess now and it's just
extraordinary that ministers keep
pursuing exactly the same gamble despite
all the evidence and cost that their
gamble keeps causing to the taxpayer to
the people stuck in this system most
certainly and to any idea that people
smuggling and human trafficking and
human exploitation is ever going to be
addressed because of course the people
who are vulnerable to all this are just
made more vulnerable if you don't attend
their needs and unfortunately the
government seems set on that
yes Steve I don't know if you're
listening to our report before we came
to you live from Ali Fortis she was
speaking to a young man who you know
made that perilous journey to seek
Asylum here in the UK and he said it was
the last chance I had and with the
government framing their legislation as
a deterrent you do wonder if any measure
the government puts in place will be an
effective deterrent to people who see
the UK as their last chance are they
fighting a losing battle on that front
the government is completely deluding
itself as well as deluding many of the
British public at the same time
people do not get into small boats they
do not make these Journeys endure the
misery not just on the last stretch of
the journey but throughout and all the
violence and mistreatment of many people
Smugglers and human traffickers they
don't endure all that for some
mere Jolly of having a chance to get
across the water they do it because they
desperately have to and unless until
ministers face up to the human reality
apart from the legal responsibilities
I'm afraid all this talk of stopping
boats rather than thinking about the
realities of people's lives is why our
policy keeps going so dramatically wrong
and Steve the government is talking
about you know cutting down on illegal
migration and they have said that they
will seek to provide more safe routes
more legal routes they'll be looking at
this but I think it was the cabinet
minister Michelle Donald over the
weekend when pressed on this couldn't
actually name any yet presumably it's in
the pipeline do you trust the government
to stay true to that
to come up with safe rooms
no because they have not been true to
that they made exactly the same promise
when they passed the last piece of
legislation less than a year ago to do
what they are now attempting to do even
more of and they created no safe routes
during that legislation or since the
simple fact is that for a very long time
now the UK has maintained a system that
requires anybody who wishes to seek
asylum in this country however much
however much connection they had to this
country
to require them to make a journey with a
Visa and get here to make that claim and
at the same time of making all those
requirements the UK maintains
immigration rules that refuse anybody
any visa to come for that purpose so
it's just utterly nonsensical I mean
effectively it's a lie a perpetrated on
the public as well there are no lawfully
provided routes by the government which
is why Smugglers Thrive and simply
ratcheting that up is just going to make
more profits for Smugglers
um Steve Valdez Simons any of those new
safe routes promised I'm sure um if the
government want to put those details out
there as alongside the new legislation
uh hopefully they will do in the coming
days as Steve Valdez Simon's there from
Amnesty International talking about the
uh new legislation the outline of which
the government are putting forward uh
this week we assume tomorrow thank you
for your time